stop the show Gang let's talk about that
middle class famous store baby oh baby
coming up to the fourth quarter on that
down to the Finish Line only a few times
to see us again gang It's a Good Time
come on out and see the live show to mix
a stand-up comedy plus we played a
little late YG with the crowd it's a
great way to introduce new people to the
show so bring the squad with you cause
we got some tickets left for the second
show in Providence Rhode Island in
December and we got some a few tickies
left for our second show in Boston in
December get those hickies let's party
gang this episode is brought to you by
our good friends at established titles
isn't it you purchase as little as one
square
keep going baby you purchase as little
as one square foot of land and you
yourself can call yourself a lord or a
lady
I'm a lord during the week a lady on the
weekends that's all it takes yeah baby
uh guys uh title packs give you at least
one square foot of dedicated land on a
private estate
Scotland hello uh an official
certificate get up the crest our accents
are all over the map today it makes an
amazing last minute gift and baby
worrying gifts giving Seasons so get one
for the boys for the girls for the Lords
established titles is running a Black
Friday sale right now plus if you use
the code garbage you get an additional
10 off go to establish titles.com slash
garbage don't talk when I'm in the ad
read established titles.com get your
gifts now and help support the channel
don't establishments.com
welcome to another exciting edition of
are you garbage the show where you find
out if your favorite comedians are
classy individuals or absolute trash now
here are your hosts Kevin Ryan and H
Foley
hey everybody out there and welcome back
to everybody's favorite new podcast this
is are you garbage it's a little show we
sit there with your favorite comedians
and we find out they're good to be
classy or if they're just a big old
piece of trash I'm your hostage Foley
coming at you on a beautiful day we're
down here at antuti's basement she just
picked up the Thanksgiving turkey okay
off the local drug dealer unless they're
here and I gotta tell you by the size of
the birds pretty good year this year for
the boys okay so shout out to ice pick
we appreciate it Mike Carlos is coming
at you from right next to me unamused
this week what are you gonna do keep the
streak going he is the CEO of Ru garbage
he is an international businessman he's
the prince of Park Avenue but always the
king of the boardwalk baby give it up
for Kevin James Ryan Hey gang thanks for
tuning in as always please make sure
your rate if you subscribe on iTunes
full video of album on YouTube as you
know those numbers are
cooking and then obviously the greatest
website of all time
www.patreon.com or you garbage check it
the [ __ ] out gang love that money me and
having a nice quick shout out to our
producer X Jordan Air the magic man
makes us all look good he works the ones
and twos he crosses the t's and he dots
the eyes give it up for T-Bone McMuffin
Toby McMullen everybody hey what up
dudes yo Pinky's out when you're sipping
your Babs boys
Sharp Dressed lady that's what I'm
talking about gang we couldn't be more
excited to have our incredibly and I
mean incredibly special guest here with
us today for the first time she's a very
funny very successful stand-up comedian
actor podcaster and now author and you
might have seen her but not limited to
do yourselves a favorite gang get
comfortable because she's an earner he's
got a rap sheet on her we got It's
Always Sunny in Philadelphia you got
Reno 9-1-1 you got the Sarah Silverman
program Aqua Teen Hunger Force till
death pretend Time free agents ugly
America 90 credits don't read these
Community arrested developers than Meryl
Streep but none of them are hits so just
stop
neighbors Inside Amy Schumer Let's Be
Cops remaining Modern Family
too many credits like it's all good
shows then we got Ellen we got camel we
got tiger belly the tonight's show this
is not happening Chelsea Lately 69
episodes of that let's go cut the check
here we go it was a really 69 episode
yes it was oh my God you got James
Corden WTF Seth Meyers The Daily Show
Joe Rogan Colbert Conan you got
Brickleberry Drunk History Superstore
BoJack Horseman American Dad dice
teachers alone together
so many credits and no one people don't
know who I am they're like oh she seems
familiar you're nuts what are you
talking about you also got Hoops you got
another period 33 episodes of that you
got Monster High the movie you got Craig
Kilbourne you got Carson Daly world's
thumb is 27 episodes of that Last Comic
Standing you got 11 on the piece for
that list in your Journal why do you
just read it off your phone ymh she has
her own comedy special special presents
she has multiple stand-up specials out
including la live at bimbos and the
honeymoon stand up special and of course
you can hear every week on Netflix and
you can hear every week on The Amazing
podcast the endless honeymoon and also
she is here endless honeymoon podcast
brand new book called The World deserves
my children the world deserves my
children yes ladies and gentlemen the
one the only Natasha Leggero let's go
come on let's go
everybody does yeah that's not all my
credits though you missed a couple say
here's a couple of ERS in there I forgot
to mention no because I looked it up
once and I had more than like most
actresses who are like very famous but
that's not a good sign
like a bunch of bit Parts sure but I
mean it's a lot if you're in a show that
goes for Five Seasons
yeah it just says one thing everything
is canceled then and you don't have as
many you have way more credits okay yes
congratulations on the book Thank you
again do yourself a favor go out and
pick it up yes absolutely amazing we're
so happy to have you here give us the
back story give us the origin story of
Natasha Leggero of my book or of my of
me of you the origin story the origin
story where are you from where'd you
grew up give us the whole deal
okay well I have to say
I'm from Rockford Illinois okay
and uh
single mom okay three kids okay I had a
brother who kind of traumatized our life
he was a bad kid okay um so that kind of
overcame a lot of our thing I was like
the mom because my mom was working all
the time my dad was Italian he kind of
was abusive towards my mom so he left
and then she kind of raised us all
herself your mom Italian too she is not
she's Swedish okay and she was a a
receptionist at a locksmith's office and
I was kind of like the babysitter and
then when I was 12 she always had me in
swim lessons and then she like put me in
a theater class because swimming was
full and then just take this girl please
well because she needed a place she
needed like she didn't have a nanny or a
babysitter daycare daycare so then the
cheerleaders were all fold up so you
were on the football team and I did go
to Catholic school so I was in this
Catholic school uniform at the theater
school or you know at the wise theater
school and they just happened to have
also a theater in Rockford that was a
regional theater and then they had
remembered me from the class when they
needed a kid so like six months later
they called St James Elementary and were
like is was there a girl they were they
were trying to find me and so they found
me and then I started to become a part
of this theater regional theater that's
that's pretty sweet I didn't get paid
like regional theater is like part
Equity so it was like parked down on the
down on their luck actors from Chicago
and part like delusional townspeople
shout out to them and then me yeah and I
was like the kid in like every show no
Randy you can't play Annie I'm sorry
come on man so I got to kind of escape
this life and become a part of the
theater which became like very dear to
me like I remember when I was like on
Hiatus or there wasn't a show and I had
to like not leave school on Wednesdays
for matinees I would like you know start
humility like like um I would just get
like hyperventilating and like I just
wanted to go back to the theater like I
was just like it was like my home you
never got paid at all for anything no I
think that's the idea with regional
theater is like the equity people get
paid
it wasn't like that that's still pretty
cool though it was cool it was it was
definitely a great education and it you
know set the path for me for my whole
life and sure I am extremely grateful
for my mother to my mother for doing
that and I hope to do the same thing for
my child there you go put them in enough
things to see what what sticks and what
I'm passionate about yeah and what
they're good at and you know I I'm like
extremely fortunate that that happened
to me because then for the you know
starting at 12 I was like I'm gonna be
an actress I'm going to be an actress so
then I went to uh do I keep going yes oh
my God please okay well do you want to
know more about my home life I mean well
yeah I know how much my mom's house cost
do you have the number one you bought it
for like sixty thousand dollars and I
think now it's worth ninety thousand
dollars in Rockford Illinois it's a very
small Bungalow okay that was an
unbelievable read of what the show is
yeah
but I mean I'm about to pull it up on
Zillow I thought you were gonna say 600
Grand 30 grand and 50 years it didn't go
it didn't go up much okay but it's you
know Rockford is the second biggest city
in Illinois it's the home of Cheap Trick
okay um which you know as I grew up I
had jobs in addition to the theater I
worked I mowed lawns you did hell yeah
okay I edged them you know what like a
manual edger I'm a dirtbag yeah I had
paper routes I actually got in trouble
once because I had like a few paper
routes I had like the Rockford Register
Star which is like the legit paper but
then I had those like other ones that
were free that people would yell at me
for giving them sure yeah and I remember
one winter I was like standing on a
corner waiting for my mom to pick me up
and I was just like dropping the pic
because people were yelling at me so I
would like give them the paper and a
woman would come out and be like do you
think address don't ever come to this
house again and so I was sitting on a
corner standing on a corner and I was
just kind of dropping the papers from my
little sack in front of me and then
kicking them into the into the um sure
yeah I respect that yeah but looking up
like no like it's not happening exactly
and some old person called the city on
me and then I got in trouble so I had a
lot of jobs and uh at what age did you
start working
probably 12. wow are you contributing to
the household no no no no no but I have
just like pocket money it was money for
me to like buy my Benetton you know
stuff or a spree and whatever I wanted
sure a couple of Bangles tapes I gotcha
okay I was more into the Smiths okay
that kind of thing did you have a uh a
Morrissey poster in your room no in my
room was The Clash I was very into like
punk rock and so I had the Clash I
remember I had a Dukakis uh sign
very interested because you're the boss
you got a Margaret Thatcher poster in
your room
you know
crap for some reason okay
and uh Dan Coyle with his eyes scratched
out
oh I remember my mom said too she took
out she's like we do not want to
you know what what you are yeah that's
classy that's very Middle America it's
like she you know keep it shut exactly
but later in life I remember my husband
put a Bernie Sanders sign outside of our
of our house in LA and I was like get
that out of here
stop it so um but I let me just say too
my whole Persona my whole Mo in life is
reinvention so I don't know if this like
butts butts up against
what you your thing for sure you're
thinking so where you are now to where
you came from I'm saying just because
you're from garbage doesn't mean of
course not so we have people that
started out not not trashy and then
became garbage we have people that
started out garbage and then like you
said reinvented themselves that's bad
started out classy became garbage I
don't wish that on anyone it's also like
money doesn't matter
you know what I mean it's not money it's
it's it's uh it's deeper than that okay
so I went to high school was in the
theater the whole time uh thought I
would get into Juilliard based on my
headshot it didn't happen
definitely delusional took it out of
Sears yeah
Olin Mills headshot I was like ready for
it I was so confident and then that
didn't happen then I auditioned for
DePaul in Chicago and they were like we
think you're better suited for our
technical theater program to which was
like that was like very
um you know that was really hard for me
to handle but they wanted to be a roadie
well I think that what happened was they
probably were like we're full so why
don't you come into the texture but I
took it very personally of course you
have to and then I have a vendetta yeah
so then I finally got into ISU on a
scholarship which had a good theater
program and I went there for two years
and then finally one day I opened up
backstage West and it said like
auditions happening for Stella Adler
Conservatory in New York City but in
Chicago was the audition so I went to
this guy's hotel room it was very odd
how things used to happen
this guy's hotel room and he admitted me
I didn't even have to touch him and
trying after the Actors Studio at an
auto body shop yikes so I did that and I
got in and then I finally got to go to
New York that's awesome and then you
know I stayed here for like four years
and couldn't get an agent it was really
rough but I did go to Stella other
Conservatory I finished my
um Community or not Community College
but I it was hard for me because I was
transferring credits from ISU to 100 or
college to Brooklyn College like I was
just trying to go to City universities
because they were cheap I think I think
Hunter was like 1200 a year it was so
cheap and are you doing this all on your
own are you paying for all this yourself
that was my mom's thing she was like you
have to go to college but she didn't pay
for it but hey you're that's your
problem you figured out that was her one
hope for me because she was like two
credits short when she married my dad
okay so that so I was like this is
really important to her I'll do it and
by the way all those young kids out
there who don't want to go to college
it's like I learned so much at college
and I took all these classes that I
would have never taken like I remember I
took a woman's study class and I learned
all about Edith Wharton and like that is
what helped me you know have plant the
seed for another period which is like
the thing I'm proudest that I did which
was a show that I created for three
seasons on Comedy Central of course
um so yeah I think that um college is
really good so I went there and I
finally got my degree and couldn't get
an agent now no stand up yet no stand up
and I was like [ __ ] this [ __ ] New York
going to La if they won't have me in New
York I'll go to La I got an agent and
then I remember I was in audition
classes or I was auditioning in New York
and or in LA because I finally got an
agent there and then I remember thinking
like all the actors were so annoying and
like So Vain in the in the waiting rooms
they were all so competitive and then
all of a sudden I would go to an improv
audition and I was like who are these
people these guys are funny and cool
wacky Vain and you know crazy but yeah
but like I was like oh I want to be in
this group of people so then I took like
every class I could find that had
anything to do with comedy if if it was
if it had anything to do with comedy and
like was like 60 miles from my house I
like took it like so I I was just took
improv Second City Groundlings stand up
comedy I just did every single thing and
you know and then I finally did stand up
for the first time and it just ended up
working out it clicked well also what I
liked about it though because you know I
I my degree from Hunter is in theater
criticism
and I was you know I was good at it and
I got like you know some I got like some
awards for it some people were like
really that was the first time people
were like oh you're really good at this
writing thing because public school and
Rockford everyone was like you're not an
artist you're not a writer it was like
very negative and so I felt really
confident and then I really felt like my
critical facilities were really kind of
um you know worked in in in this you
know going to the theater in New York
and like writing reviews so then I feel
like when I got to La I was like very
critical and so when I saw someone do
stand up that I knew I was like oh I can
just like stand up on stage and make fun
of how stupid everyone in La is there
you go because these people don't know
anything and I was working at The
Whiskey Bar and you see these girls come
in who were like actresses and so I was
just able to react to it all in like a
way that was
um you know when I saw the girl do it on
stage I was like oh I think I could do
that it was just this girl I knew named
Melanie Vesey who went to Stella Adler
and I I didn't know about any comedians
or you know I didn't know who Sarah
Silverman was or any of these like
hilarious comedians so I feel like I was
so lucky that I just was kind of naive
yeah and then I just kind of went for it
when it when it happened and you know
that was like 25 years ago so you got a
degree from Hunter College yes and then
you finished the program at Stella Adler
Conservatory that was a two-year acting
conservatory and then it was like
impossible to get into by the way it's
very reputable is it okay
people weren't that good at it but you
know everybody kind of sucked if I'm
being honest with it well it might be
whatever you say Pinhead I've never been
shot down for picking someone up I know
no no but let me just tell you I was in
the no it was it was very reputable we
learned all about Stella Adler and we
had the same teachers that taught the
NYU students all the rich kids so like
we had all the same teachers but we were
in like this different kind of program
kind of for like the losers sure but
I've been in one of those programs yeah
but yes I'm so anyway I'm babbling I
mean you asked me to tell you myself
so you did still out of the first then
went down to college then went to 100 so
you were here for six years five years
five years and then you know what
happened what happened 9 11. really
well and I was living I was living in
Harlem well I was in LA at the time but
I was I was living in Harlem and I had
subletted my place because I was still
like trying to find how out like sure do
I moved to L.A who's gonna respond to me
and um yeah and then I was like oh 911
like let's let's let's get the [ __ ] out
get to the coast we're out of here yeah
it's at the valley huh all right
pretty classy Journey there sure she's a
real like bootstrapper I think I really
got like a ball under you go you do it
you figure it out you tell people to go
[ __ ] themselves you get on stage the
whole nine I forgot the best part the
reason I was able to get to LA because I
didn't have much money I was waitressing
living in Harlem and then Chase
Manhattan bank which I couldn't say in
the books they're like you can't say
Chase Manhattan Bank we don't give a
[ __ ] to say it baby come get it I this
is one of I guess the Privileges of
being a white person is they just sent
me an email or there wasn't even email
them they sent me a letter saying like
congratulations you just got five
thousand dollars in overdraft protection
and so like my account at Chase Bank all
of a sudden had like this 5 I could
write checks up to five thousand dollars
of what you don't have more than what I
had in yeah so I was like immediately
like I found like a rent a wreck in la
like a car rental company that would
take checks
you overdrafted your whole future on
overdrafting your account five grand
your trash so they didn't exactly send
you five thousand dollars no that's the
way you were living I respect it yeah
yeah that's the show so
able to write all these checks
to get to L.A all these bad checks yeah
they weren't bad though I mean I
eventually they weren't good they were
not good and let's not forget I probably
paid fifteen thousand dollars
to pay all that back because there was a
time in LA when I first got there I
would I had a post office box I would
just check my mail I would open the post
office box open it and anything that was
a bill I would just throw in the garbage
I still do that oh yeah I put it back in
the mailbox you gotta send that [ __ ]
certified
otherwise I didn't say you're gonna have
to serve me dude that's not I was out of
town all weekend you have to serve me if
you want that Victoria's Secret 200 by
the way and this was so so many stupid
decisions like it's all bad purchases
you would buy like one thing for 180 and
it would just stay with you for 10 years
I'm just getting out of that yeah uh I'm
sorry yeah well you're you're in your
30s that's what your 30s are about I
mean I did it when I was 18 but still
okay let's talk about Aura oh baby or
afraid let's talk about Aura frames gang
if you're like me and the bald guy hey
you got pictures everywhere you got him
an Instagram you got him a Facebook you
got some wedding photographer we'll call
you back because you didn't make the
deposit or she dumped you or whoever it
goes either way wouldn't it be nice to
have all those pictures in one place
that's where I put my nudes
real tasteful stuff though
guys it does have a frame that fits any
style that's what I'm saying baby and
everything looks bigger on that frame
you know what I mean gang every Aurora
frame is designed to fit any decor with
stunning HD display and limited storage
super easy setup and here's the kicker
what's that no fees baby oh God guys I
simply connect Aurora frame the Wi-Fi
and use the free Aura app to add endless
pics and videos hey Shark Tank let's go
yeah you know my friends and family on
the app did you just say that listen
it's a great gift for you listen you got
to know you gotta yeah I gave one to the
knee shut up and buy it what are we
doing here I gave on to Denise the Beats
this broad loves it she's got picks all
the kids on any old broads the
grandparents that's how you get them
they love the picks and they they're not
great with pixel what makes it easy
peasy for them guys from now through
Black Friday and Cyber Monday listeners
can get 50 off Ora's best-selling frames
just go to auraframes.com garbage that's
a-u-r-a-frames.com garbage
these are Orr's lowest prices ever and
get yours before they sell out terms and
conditions applied do it okay let's talk
about them true classic teeth baby maybe
I got about a bajillion of them at the
house yeah I'm talking to you fatties
and uggles and Piggies out there uh-huh
gang do yourself a favor you want the
most comfortable most flattering t-shirt
that could ever fit on on a big guy do
yourself a favor and pick up some of
those true classic teas baby they fit
perfect because here's the thing them
other t-shirts are designed to fit guys
in shape guys not us if you're rocking a
little bit of a dad bottle if you're a
fat pig like me you need something to
cover some things up and let me tell you
something it's the gift that gives to
everybody to you to your girl anybody
eating the neighbors any little kids
sure you're not scaring everybody away
yeah best t-shirts in the biz they're
the most comfortable shirts I ever wore
when I want to hide my saggy tits I
reach for clue true classic tees they
got polos they got work out there they
got boxer brings they got
get 25 off at trueclassic.com garbage
free shipping included on purchases over
a hundred bucks there you go that's 25
off at trueclassic.com garbage Santa
won't be the only one slaying thanks to
True classic all right uh let's go back
ahead let's go back to Illinois for a
minute
um so you guys had a single family home
your mom had you guys said one bathroom
two bedrooms okay kids two floors one
floor although they did put the my
brother in the basement okay finished
basement
[Laughter]
let the mold really sink in
um well now that that house was on oh
wait there wasn't attic we redid
eventually but not when I was there okay
uh does anybody still live there now my
mother she died so without giving away
the the the the the name of the street
was it a street a road an Avenue was it
Avenue it was in a nice part of town too
it was like in a very historic kind of
okay house is it was a nice place to
grow up and what was the name of the
grocery store that you went to as a kid
not only did I uh go to it I worked at
it was called Highlander gone now sounds
pretty prestigious the Highlander and
and uh Cheap Trick uh Rick Nielsen would
come in and I would be working and I
would I was so Starstruck by him whoever
I was waiting on if I saw him like
figuring out which one you know who had
the shortest line I would just start
giving people their stuff for free take
this let us get the [ __ ] out of my face
and a few times I got him
I don't know what I thought he was a
go-getter dude
these are two cents off shut up lady get
out of here oh okay that's growing up
we had a Cocker oh we had a Cocker
Spaniel and then we also had a um you
tell someone's garbage from their dogs
well if you have lizard snakes
Turtles hamsters gerbils and we we had a
uh what are the the brown one not a
golden retriever um Labrador Labrador
okay not bad you're so classy the
thought of people owning Birds yeah
you're like a loose bird family it's a
little different no birds no you ever
bring animals from the inside like like
rehab a squirrel or anything like that
no we're no okay my mom was actually I
think she was aspiring like to to have
like a speed classy yeah okay well
because you carry yourself with a lot of
class you do thank you absolutely but I
think yeah I think it's a little dirty
under those fingernails we'll get into
it
she just actually a little dirty under
those gels I like it
um High School mascot
oh my God this is rough e-rab huh what
it was like is that a rapper I know it
was like East it stood for because I
went to East High School and it stood
for East red and black uh-huh okay but
it was it an animal or was it a guy I
think it was it looked like a Native
American face or something with a mask
on it was not a good thing okay okay all
right fair enough uh what was the family
vacation like growing up
we didn't really do vacations no
vacations any weekend or anything no
Disney World we went to Epcot Center
once when my mom had this boyfriend that
drove us there he drove you from
Illinois from Illinois what kind of car
was that
Maxima diesel whoa Nissan yeah maximum
they make diesels I just remember the
silver diesel yeah and like pulling over
on the shoulder to take a nap with the
full car
I think this is why I'm like I want to
be on a permanent vacation now it makes
sense yeah yeah did people have
vacations every ever all the time uh I
don't remember anyone I knew really we
went down the show we went down to the
Jersey Shore so we would go we would do
that a little bit different we're
outside of Philly it was a little bit I
never went to Disney World okay yeah
never yeah my mom went with her
girlfriends once when I was like the
bachelorette party
somebody blew Mickey
get a lap dance from Snoopy any sports
as a kid
uh my brothers were in soccer I was in
swimming and Diving and I have a uh I I
have a whole photo album full of yellow
ribbons which is the fourth place
um they put quit bragging will you they
put me in because I was really good I
could do butterfly because like a lot of
people could do all the sport you know
midwesterner is a very broad shouldered
I'm not like a typical swimmer's body so
um they would put me in the IM which is
individual medley which is breaststroke
backstroke freestyle and then finishing
it off with the butterfly and I just
remember doing like when I'm doing the
butterfly just like a whole like the
stadium just of Silence just waiting for
me to be done because everyone was
already done and so well that's the
saddest [ __ ] I've ever heard like a fat
guy running a marathon but I still got
like a yellow ribbon and a point for the
team for finishing okay and um I'm glad
I mean I'm glad I got to be such a good
swimmer you know yeah fourth place all
right two too shabby a lot of people
though I'll hang out with them and they
don't know how to swim they don't know
my husband doesn't know The Strokes he
doesn't know backstroke he doesn't know
breaststroke so it's like I know the
stroke so like I'm actually above him
now and I've swam with people and
they're like wow you really know how to
do all this but I can't really compete
with it but I mean I could do a lot of
Strokes you can yeah okay I scream is a
lighter fella yes I can I can do I do
butterflies do breaststroke do
backstroke the whole nine yards what's
your favorite one
if I could do it really good it would be
butterfly that's the coolest one yeah I
mean that's
that's all right anybody can swim
freestyle you know and if a shark's
chasing you you get moving
any bands you playing any bands as a kid
no you play any instruments now uh I'm
learning piano oh I see that's the
classiest thing what was your first
concert
Liberace
really or Air Supply I don't remember
[ __ ] you can't leave with Liberace and
then say or Air Supply but my mom took
me it was either a Mozart or Insane
Clown Posse I can't remember well I just
remember I I have three memories I
remember Kenny Rogers Air Supply and
Liberace at the Rockford metro center
like being like way too little to be at
a concert but like just seeing it you
know what I mean like my mom must have
been on a date and not had a babysitter
or something Liberace I remember him and
I I honestly I remember him like it I
was thinking he was phoning it in really
must have been the Late Show huh it was
just like a lot of like what was he
doing crowd work this is good enough for
you Rockford
didn't even like to cut the candles yeah
what's up Toledo oh yeah there was a
piano with candelabra yeah and then Air
Supply I remember there was like a laser
show and then what age we talk in here
it must have been like
five to eight I don't know it was like
young man shout out to Air Supply though
all out of love that's that's a hit I
don't know who you are
um what would be uh as a kid what would
be like a Treat night out to go to
dinner would that ever happen would they
take you like the ground round or like
Red Lobster or anything like that would
you guys do anything like that there was
an Italian restaurant called Lino's that
I really like sounds nice and it was it
was like kind of like the classic it
wasn't a chain but it's like what all
the chains are copying gotcha yeah I bet
you they put on a plate of pasta oh my
God it was so good and I just went back
because my dad died and I took my that's
okay I hate saying it because everyone's
like I'm so sorry
um but it'll be weird if I didn't how
was the veal parmesan but I told my
husband I was like you have to try this
pasta it's so amazing so we get there
and then of course Moshe he doesn't eat
pork and he's just like talking to the
waiter and he's like so there's no meat
in the sauce they're like no no it's
because I remember it was just a red
sauce and they're like no no they're
like well there is um there is bone
broth in the sauce and he's like should
I ask him what kind of bone broth it is
he's like maybe it's chicken and I was
like no it's obviously pork and a red
sauce yeah of course
so then he eats their like non you know
like their special one for annoying
people and then he's like I don't think
that place was that good
garlic bread they do garlic bread there
oh for sure gnocchi with the bone broth
red sauce all right that's all right uh
do you drink milk with dinner growing up
no what was your local pizza place what
was the name of that
I mean I guess that was Lino's you get
pizza from here though yeah nothing like
a pizza Italian restaurant together it's
the best where would you rent a movie
from
uh
uh I don't even remember local video
where's Blockbuster or West Coast hit
the town
it was something local that I don't
remember I'm sorry this is like these
are this is like therapy how are the
grades High School
a lot of C's a lot of C's a lot of D's
in conduct okay good at uh well I went
to a creative performing arts program in
middle school so I was you know I was
good and
theater uh how about the SATs probably
took the acts I took acts how do you
know that
because what it is okay yeah I took the
acts I don't know if I should tell this
story no that's what we want I basically
because I was really good in like
English
and you know all the Arts I took Fiber
Arts
it's like um you know like making
baskets and stuff there was a lot of
like handiwork for the girls you were
getting C's well I was getting good
grades in that but like I'm saying Math
Science History that stuff was really
bad she was good with macaroni and glue
whatever like was the advanced preschool
stuff
uh you finger painted this
so the acts I remember walking in and I
saw this girl who I knew was smart and I
just sat next to her and then for the
science part I I just cheated yeah I
respect that that's not true that's
class I cheated science and math what
are you gonna come and arrest you you
could tell that what'd you get uh I got
good enough to get into college okay
there you go you know because I was on
my road just something get out of
Rockford there you go I like it
um what was Christmas like you guys do
lights on the house no lights on the
house but Christmas was like you know my
dad's family has seven kids and all of
those and all of those people have like
two families and like all the cousins
and the drunk Italian that's the Italian
side then every my dad must have got
Christmas in the in the custody because
like that was Christmas was like my dad
Christmas night you know like so we
would go there and it would you do Seven
Fishes what's that that were they eat
Italian fishes you guys didn't do that
no okay they might not have known about
that all right they're Midwest
a lot of drunk people arguing about did
you [ __ ] my wife or you know like that
kind of fighting sounds like my family
party people driving home drunk and uh
real Christmas tree real Chris might so
my this was a thing with my mom she
always thought my dad's family was kind
of trash and so then they had like a
flocked Christmas tree what's that it's
white flocks you know like white
Italians love a white Christmas tree
I've been saying it since the start of
this at the start of this show I've
never met anybody that actually had one
Italians love except for Henry Hill and
my dad or my mom the gaudiest thing in
the world and my mom talk about new
money they don't do that
yeah of course and my mom would always
have a real one nice classy that's
classy okay it's crazy stockings too we
did stockings yeah so then Christmas
morning was with my mom nice
uh anybody ever been on the local news
in the family
me only me really for good reasons well
my brother who's the best paper scandal
no no I I mean no when we were growing
up yeah no no okay but I will say my
brother seems to know the law like
people who get in trouble sounds like my
kind of guy that's 82.78 right there you
can't touch me like he has a course
you piece of [ __ ] yeah exactly like
actually he spent the pandemic in with
it he got his uh in what's it called
when you can't travel probation or um
parole he was a parole parole because he
was getting gas he tells me the story
he's like yeah I'm in the gas station
I'm going to get myself some drink and I
see this guy without a mask and I'm like
Hey brother why don't you put on a mask
and then I'm pumping my gas and the guy
comes up to me and he's within 11 feet
of me so then I pumped her in the face
I'm like he didn't even punch you in the
face he's like no so he just kind of
knew the law that like like you're
encroaching my person exactly I'm
allowed to feel threatened exactly but
it didn't work because then he got his
you know I got jammed up exactly so he I
like this guy though yeah he's all right
I like this Hulk Hogan too but he is not
we're not like him you know like none of
my fam like all the siblings are
different I feel like okay gotcha what
was the bike situation growing up what
were you riding I was riding a pink
10-speed Huffy 10 speeds back in the day
were clay
remember it went like that oh man when
those dropped that was crazy yeah okay
that might as well been a professional
and by the way I biked everywhere I
loved biking no helmet and I would bike
to my job I would bike to my friend's
house I would bike around the
neighborhood loved it could you ride to
10 speed without your hands on the on
the bus oh my God I remember doing it
good so cool yeah that is cool going
down a hill without my hands and I
remember my friend telling me like yeah
I saw you coming down that hill without
your handsomething you probably heard a
little buzz going around Rockford in the
80s and 90s there was nothing funny that
you know that because by the way I
haven't thought of that since I thought
of it when I was going down that Hill
yeah so thank you for that and I love to
bike now so
um how old were you when you got your
passport
uh
21 no no wait I went to England yes when
I was at ISU at Illinois State
University I was like I gotta get the
[ __ ] out of here so I did like an
exchange program in England okay I went
to England okay well you you weren't the
first one in your family to travel
abroad right you were and my parents
both never traveled abroad okay wow all
right how many points did that get me
it's negative three yeah I'm the same
way I didn't get my I didn't get my
passport until last year yeah last year
I'm 40. last year I'm 46. honey yeah
Henry I went to Delaware too you just
hit you with a honey yeah
okay how about our good friends over
there at manscape huh it's the holidays
gang do yourselves a favor don't forget
about the jingle balls down there you
know what I'm saying they gotta keep
them fresh keep the berry dingers thanks
this is what things happen you're at a
party office party you want to make sure
the nuts are fresh yeah and that you're
ready for some action eggnog's going
around you're another mistletoe next
yeah no she's reaching through your
pubes or longer than your piece yeah get
trimmed up down there that's at least
that's what they told me guys manscape
performance package 4.0 has got it all
baby the lawnmower 4.0 body trimmer we
got the weed whacker nose and ear hair
trimmers get that [ __ ] you reach a
certain age you got to keep that [ __ ]
clean that's no good it's got the skin
safe technology protected to protect
your holes babies yeah you know what to
do plus it's waterproof I throw it in
the shower clean the ears for God's
sakes uh guys you got 20 off and free
shipping with code garbage at
manscape.com that's 20 off and free
shipping with code garbage at
manscape.com be thankful this holiday
season for the best gift from best gift
of all from manscape your balls will
thank you camp let's talk about
established titles again
I'm gonna tell you what tell the stable
boy to get my Steed I have to ride over
to my land over there in the Scottish
Woodlands dang as you know established
titles you pick up just one square foot
of Scottish Woodland land and you
yourself can call yourself a lord or a
lady hello uh-huh you guys get a
certificate that has a plot number so
you can see the location of your land
and baby the hook is let's be neighbors
the first 200 people purchasing the
title pack using our link will
effectively be next to our plots within
a few minutes of walking let's start an
army of garbage and take over those
goddamn Scots over there it's a good
time it's a good gift yeah uh you can
officially change your name to Lord of
Lady put on a credit card plane tickets
add some class to your dating profile uh
it makes a great gift and it's not a gag
gift it's a good time it's fun it's cool
it's sketchy established titles is
running a Black Friday sale plus if you
use the code garbage you'll get an
additional 10 off go to
establisheshadows.com get your gifts now
and help support the channel do it uh
did you go anywhere went to France oh
did you love it oh forget about it oh
it's the best and then shout out to you
can't get better food sister you ain't
lying and it's so close to so many other
places you gotta go back and go to like
we're gonna go back okay good we're
gonna go back uh what was your uh were
you Cabbage Patch doll yes for sure how
many did you have
one just one okay
I actually might have had the imitation
one there you go all right I feel like
I'm I'm purposefully answering
everything to be sad but I'm really good
no that's good you would be more you'd
be trashy if you had oh we collected
them we had six of them yeah that's
trash having one's normal okay good okay
keeping one of the boxes it's a
collector's item or something no
um at any point did any of your family
cars have a beaded seat cover no no no
no okay
you ever see a taping of Double Dare
oh what is that the Nickelodeon show no
no I remember um you can't do that on
television sure oh man that was a great
show and then my mom got one of those
because I was really into Yom TV wraps
and 120 minutes and then Tipper Gore
came out remember and she was like don't
let your kids watch MTV so my mom got a
lock for um for cable so she would lot
or maybe for certain channels so she had
like a padlock so we couldn't watch MTV
anymore so I had to watch like Nick at
night how's the padlock
I don't know it was like it was like a
little thing she had the people come
over and do damn yikes one's a tight
ship [ __ ] Tipper Gore right hmm when was
the last time you had a Hot Pocket
we didn't really do that okay no we ate
more like Lipton rice and soup you know
that thing we made a lot of that yeah
that's good yeah the door noodles yeah
we did that they were pretty good they
were all right we get mayonnaise family
you have mail in the house back in the
day yeah sure was it Hellman's or was it
no Miracle Whip honey good okay I think
my mom was like actually like
purposefully trying to do everything
that you think is like the opposite of
everything you think is crashing sure
well that's a lot of things a lot of
people that are expected that are you
know from that error or whatever try to
not be trash like there's no way we're
doing I'm gonna work extra hard to
happen exactly like we had to look on
the back of cereal boxes and we could
only have things that were the fourth
ingredient was sugar oh wow really what
was your favorite cereal growing up well
I loved Fruity Pebbles but I couldn't
eat that sure so I think I ate like you
know Frosted Mini weights or something
Frosted Mini Wheats are all right
especially if you leave a couple on top
or they're crunchy with everything else
is soggy underneath real nice not bad uh
did you guys keep your butter on the
counter and the refrigerator
so I want to catch you on that by the
way let me just tell you I have a friend
who went to Harvard and he said to me
once he's like do you know you say both
with an L both give me both are you both
of yous coming how do you say it and
he's like both both how do you say it
both both see I say it wrong both like a
bolt of fabric but both both yeah I get
that though I say does anybody I say
library sometimes what no that is not
even compare what do you call this what
do you call the stuff that you put on
top of your pancakes
syrup syrup what do you call it syrup
syrup
that is hey we're judging you here
came in here and flipped it on me
anybody anybody in the family ever
claimed to have seen a UFO no wait I'm
starting to think I'm not as much
garbage as I thought you're doing all
right so far
the line any lifeguards or magicians in
your family
the pronunciation tip how do you
pronounce the product that Crayola makes
oh my God my husband and I get in this
fight all the time because he gets so
mad at me he's like they are not called
crayons crayons that's what I say and he
said I said what are they called he's
like crayons crayons Crayola I say
crowns which is crowns don't judge me
what the [ __ ] is this I said and he's
like I don't want my daughter saying
cringe it's not cram it's crayons
country draws the line I like it that's
awesome but isn't it some of that
Regional it is it is it is okay uh do
you have a go-to karaoke song hmm I
can't really I like um well it came to
me you know later but I like any country
song is good any Loretta Lynn song any
you know old school country old school
country easy to see classy
um have you ever bought something worn
it and returned it to the store
oh for sure and shoplifted okay
also killed a guy in Reno one time just
to watch him die
ah uh does your family make anything
homemade like do you guys pickle
anything or anything like that
no no no all right no I'm just thinking
like now I have friends at ISU who were
like parents were farmers and they were
those are like deer jerky and stuff so I
know where you're going with this yeah
we did not do that did you have a sweet
16
no no okay uh when you started uh making
uh when you started doing well okay
making a little bit you've been touring
for a while this is like 30 years old
though I stopped my waitressing job
we're fully aware you've been killing it
for a while so when you start when you
started uh making good money was there a
silly
anything like that or have you always
been pretty smart with your finances
you know I like experiences okay
I think there was a few times
there was a few times I would be on the
road and I would pick a hotel that was
more than I was making you're a nice
hotel kind of gal you like that you like
a finer thing in life I feel yes you do
all right so I was like you know what
I'm performing people are loving it I
don't care if I spend my whole check on
this hotel that's my kind of action
let's see what we're talking about stay
at the Ritz in Omaha
well it was more like the hotel St
Cecilia in Austin but I don't even know
what that is but it said well I was
staying there and then I was like okay
this is an absurd amount of money to
spend tonight I gotta go check into
somewhere else and I checked into
somewhere else and it was like I can't
stay here after that yeah
and I was like [ __ ] it so but you know
you don't do things like that when you
don't have money of course sure of
course
uh all right big purchase what kind of
car are you whipping in what do I drive
I don't like cars okay but I do I drive
a black mini convertible okay
um because the mini is very practical
you can all of a sudden have parking
where other people can't have parking
and it's safe because I have a car seat
in the back and uh I just think it looks
cool it's the only cool looking American
car in my opinion and it's cheap yeah
it's not even I do like it myself is
that the family car no my husband has a
Tesla unfortunately okay right
unfortunately why I don't like the Tesla
you don't like to test it no it's like
uh it's it's even just have you guys
driven in one you guys don't drive here
no I I take it in the back of one in an
Uber that's too small for me I'm too
fast it feels like plant it feels like a
toy but what's annoying about is like
just to open the glove compartment you
have to go into like three different
places on a computer that's not my
that's not for me kick Rock give me a
Ford Taurus all day yeah
I'm a Jeep Cherokee man that's how I
roll do you wash your fruit
yes you do you got it right pretty good
not necessarily
what kind of air freshener do you have
in the car no come on nothing no I I
hate air fresheners my husband will put
one in the car and I'm like we don't do
that let's hit we don't do that you keep
the car pretty clean like that no you
don't keep it well I have a kid that's
for sure there's like you know molding
Cheerios and all that kind of stuff
um when you get the car washed will you
take the car to get it washed
no no you just Let It Rock huh okay I
mean I have an assistant who'll help me
once a week there you go once in a while
that's pretty crazy
[Laughter]
yeah you know go get the car washed and
no air freshener and don't make eye
contact with me either we don't do that
no I just I had like a helper you know
of course I have to do with my family I
need help of course
um listen this is something we Revel in
you've worked your ass off you deserve
everything you have we want to hear
about that yeah of course okay we love
that
um so you get take out right you in the
fam you're home oh for sure you could
take out yes you get it in the house
it's in the bags do you put it on a
plate or do you eat it out of the
container I can't stand all the
styrofoam and it's really I will always
try to present it and like like I made
it
that's nice I think it's important
because the styrofoam is depressing and
and also I try to order from places that
don't like overdo the styrofoam you know
it's hard but some of the more hipper
places will have like those little boxes
yeah
they get a Whole Foods if we were to
come to your house and ask for a glass
of water how would we receive it uh you
would get it probably in like a cute you
know maybe like a I have these little
Moroccan glasses you know like any
bottles at the house I would not give
you a pla no I don't have plastic like
the one we gave you no by the way my dad
is so funny he's Italian and his whole
thing was like spring water when he
would come visit us he's like I need to
I need to go buy spring water and I'm
like what what's spring water and he's
like in Colombian coffee we have to get
Colombian coffee but his whole thing was
spring water and I was like no dad the
water here is filtered and he didn't
trust it sure he only wanted to go get
water real estate store in plastic he
would get like a 24 pack of like plastic
bottle models and me and my husband are
like something you can trust is awful
and not to mention he'd like fill the
refrigerator with sausage and cheese and
motion would like open the fridge and
just be like the Italians are in town
do you do sparkling water or just
regular I do like sparkling wine at the
restaurant sparkling struggling at the
restaurant Lacroix in the house
and if you came to my house I'd probably
first offer you Lacroix and I would say
which of these six flavors do you want
what's your go-to drops the six flaves
on you lime is good okay just back to
the water thing so we get it in a nice
little questions like you know all you
know what I'm gonna say you know don't
make me say it it's the line we would
get it in a nice Moroccan glass but what
is it actually coming from is it coming
from the the faucet or something from
the refrigerator that has a filtration
system and what's that refrigerator is
it Viking sub Z what are you rocking
um I don't get too into like that kind
of stuff I just got whatever you know is
it silver or is it silver of course it
is open this it's not a pulper okay yeah
it opens though where's this where's the
freezer on the bottom yeah yeah it is
yep but I'm not one of those people who
has like you know it's like wallpapered
uh refrigerator
is that classy that's kind of seems
tacky I'm trashy but it's classy to me
it's stupid to pay ten thousand dollars
for a refrigerator like that that's a
classy answer do you have a pool at the
house
I do nice above ground
do they even have those in L.A I don't
know I've never been invited
um okay is it salt water fresh water
it's a mix
does it have the Beach entry or the
steps
um well it was it's from the the house
the pool was put in the house in the 70s
but what's cool about it is it had a
diving board which I did get rid of
because I have kids and I was like I
don't want to be the house that has like
a fatality sure but the pool does go to
like eight feet which is holy [ __ ] not
very common that's awesome so you can
dive into the pool yeah yeah just the
deep end sure but then the the shallow
end you step in I think yeah okay is
there a Jacuzzi attached to it is there
any waterfalls there's like a little bit
of a fall yeah I already did it is make
it as as cool as I could it's awesome I
was going to the bathroom you got his
and her sinks no just one sink well I I
restored my house so it was like old 50s
bathroom so I tried to kind of keep what
was there a little bit of that Vibe they
didn't really do that then anything
heated is the floor heated no no no no
no that would be nice though I do
appreciate it shower and a tub or a tub
in the shower in the same thing yes it's
the same plan one yeah no no there's a
there's a shower and then also a tub
rainfall no it's an old shower okay
glass tub is the tub have the line the
tub is like from the 40s so it's like is
it those got the claws on it no it's
like a built-in you know those pink
bathrooms that everybody has they don't
have those in New York no we did my last
apartment had a pink panther okay it's
like those pink bathrooms from the 40s
it has that so I kind of kept it all but
then like restored it
well because I love houses I love I love
old things very much so I try to keep
whenever I move to a house I'm like what
can I keep you know that is beautiful
and I'm not like a let's let's knock
this knock knock it's not over yeah okay
all right how many pillows are on the
bed
eight eight pillows duvet cover
here's the thing I'm over it I think I
just like this past two months I'm like
I don't like duvets like I because like
all I have to put it on you know and I'm
just like so this is not tenable and so
then I looked at parachute and they
actually have blankets that are like a
duvet and you can just put that in the
washer so I'm in the process of changing
over because I think maybe we've evolved
past that did you grow up with a duvet
no no and it's horrified I only found
out we didn't grow up with comforters we
had blankets yeah I think it's British
or no remember bed spreads
whoa I haven't heard that word the best
is in is an unduveted down comforter
that like a white one that's the nice
and cool between the legs those are the
best hey that's that's what that's what
I thought but then a friend stayed over
and they were complaining there wasn't
like a duvet cover but he was like a
rich kid so he was like where's my duvet
cover and I thought it was okay to just
put a full sheet on top of the duvet
because I see hotels do that sometimes
yes they do we to have some kind of like
Solution that's why I'm like the
parachute's expensive but I'm like what
is the solution to me not having to like
spend 25 minutes trying to find the the
and they could they could scrunched down
at the bottom of the duvet it's a whole
nightmare it is a nice feeling though
King Matt King bed
California King
California you got a TV in the room I do
is that does that give me but oh oh I
got more points because I don't have a
TV in my living room
because I don't want to have TV in there
because I want it to be more of like a
place for people to talk and sure that's
a classy response
um what do you fall asleep with the TV
on no you guys sleep with a fan on you
no how many pillows do you use when you
actually sleep
um barely one really I like to sleep
either flat or on like my oldest pillow
that has like feathers it's like very
very flat and you sleep on your back
on your side okay okay
don't come with an 11 feet of me
but have you noticed like sometimes if I
sleep at a hotel with like a real puffy
pillow
my next the next day my neck the hotel
pillows kill me yeah because they're
beat up they've been getting people
[ __ ] you know a lot of strangers
really start thinking about how gross
hotels are I have to stop we had a wild
year of touring and it's like get it I
if I think about it I'm like I can't
people are probably like picking their
toenails right and like doing anything
yeah that's what we're doing
I blow myself sure what I'm doing I blow
my nose in the sheets
I mean it's bad and then there's no
airflow at all they just turn the air
conditioning on there's no window very
scary have you ever stayed at an Airbnb
of course every all the time okay and I
would I would venture to argue that that
is not a good question because there's a
lot of really beautiful Airbnb I agree I
just wasn't sure your stance on them oh
I loved them especially during covet and
also they have Windows that open and I'm
like kind of a fresh air we got thrown
out of one in the Hollywood Hills
yesterday
smoking on a property got me on the ring
got him on the ring camera smoking weed
or something cigarettes three a.m right
now
that's I mean we were like their second
house on the hill it wasn't like we were
[ __ ] and you were outside yeah in the
driveway yeah
did uh you or anybody in the family
participate in Hands Across America
sounds familiar but no we absolutely did
not okay was that like an AIDS thing uh
it was something that was the age quilt
Hands Across America was it was for
Hunger or something like that yeah I
think so um what was the last meal you
cooked
hold on and are you making dinner at the
house you guys cook I make dinner
sometimes my husband does most of the
cooking nice
um
I mean
I don't really cook that much it's okay
where do you where do you guys food shop
now
um air one or whatever it's called erwan
is I think the most expensive grocery
store in America crazy they have a 26
smoothie
and it's called the Haley Bieber
smoothie and it has that Aid
I got the check what's that stuff it's
like aspert aspartame maybe whatever
that fake sugar sweetness so disgusting
yeah aspartame or whatever
um but yeah we order a lot of food my
husband makes a lot of like uh you know
rice vegetable that kind of like he's a
very healthy cook but like Flavor bomb
so like lots of salt lots of seasoning
okay I don't hate it it's uh you know we
try to stay healthy I guess eat as
healthy as possible you have any fruit
trees in your in your yard yes you do
the lemon tree and a fig tree orange
that's like generational well fig tree
[ __ ] what the [ __ ] got a fig tree a
lot of people in L.A you guys need to
get out of Manhattan okay do you want a
railroad yeah a fig tree how much cash
you have on you right now
actually I have that you're gonna hate
this dancer what 70 euros
damn dude that's the classiest [ __ ] I
ever heard a thousand miles away from
the closest country to take Europe
when's the last time you were in Europe
yes if it wasn't this morning what's
happening well I like I don't know I
just keep seeing it in there I need to
get rid of it eventually but
holy [ __ ] you got Euros on her I had
twenty dollars but I gave it to the cab
driver she's got the fancy yeah
oh I do have a 20. you guys can have
these Euros no get out of here if you're
going back to England maybe it'll make
you but I should get rid of that how
much not 70 30. wait they're not Euros
they're pounds
I had Euros I gave the Euros to my house
you feel like they're covered in wax
I've never touched them you know what's
crazy about pounds is like they have to
replace do you know they're replacing
all of this money with Charles's face
yeah they got to it's long but in Canada
I have to do that doesn't that seem like
a waste of everyone's life a lot of time
how do you get how do you get everyone's
like what happens
are they not going to take this nope Liz
is out the kids in let's go but 40
pounds is kind of like 60 60 bucks that
was the pound not doing great maybe it
went down yeah it went down the Euro and
the last time I was in Germany like a
month or two ago and it was the dollar
was better than the Euro and the Euro's
been doing better than the pound I
believe hey Jim Cramer zip it bye bye
bye uh where did you guys get married
in my yard in your yard under a fig tree
well I don't really believe like that
was that's something I would give his
advice to anyone who's getting married
like how can you like make it sweet but
like don't people will rip you well I
don't like to get ripped off and I feel
like wedding is like some a great place
for you to get completely like you know
and how long ago was it he got married
seven years ago you were married seven
years a small wedding
uh maybe like 200 people or something
maybe 100 and 100 199 I don't know
we have a big yard let's ask let's ask
this what was uh what was the biggest
gift that you guys got
well I did this thing that's kind of
trashy which is a honey fund so like you
told people to not give you a gift just
give you money towards your vacation
when you didn't take the girl to
Rockford you can't take the Rockford out
of the girl did you do well yeah we got
ten thousand dollars to go to Bora Bora
that's how much it costs to go there you
know okay let's say weddings are a big
topic a discussion around here around
these parts are you guys married I am
yes okay he is not not
um who are you
um let's see you're going to a wedding
right I don't do you have like a niece
or a friend of a fam somebody you're
going to a wedding somebody tight not
like soup not like uh you know not a
brother or sister or something like but
you know relatively close and you do
better than that family okay what are
you putting in the envelope
you're both going you and your husband
and U.S American dollars not this
British pound [ __ ] I do 200.
because I feel like 100 is the lowest
you can go and if I feel like that's if
I think that they need is that 200
American dollars so 100 for you 100 for
your date
um I would do that for myself too no 200
and 200. if if I felt like the people
needed it but a lot of people I don't
know if people are asking you for money
what do you do
more than that no kidding uh yeah I'll
probably I'll probably do 200 and 200.
dude two for me two for two four hundred
yeah Straight Cash that's amazing I mean
maybe maybe I should do more no but it's
also too like that makes sense I who we
just had somebody in here talking about
that as well of like why am I gonna give
them money oh Bobby Lee I was like why
am I gonna give
rich people rich people money it is and
I go yeah that makes sense he goes I
don't even go he doesn't even give a
card that guy
all right that makes sense by the way I
knew I knew when Bobby bought a car in
cash and then like lost the car yeah
they had like two Honda Civics oh I
didn't know the punch line yeah bought
the same exact car you didn't know about
like insurance he is special with money
ever been to the circus
uh maybe we went I don't think so have
you ever left a bad Yelp review
you know oh no ding ding ding ding ding
I think I've gotten mad before sure I
get it everybody loses the temperature I
think 26 bucks for a smoothie it's
always Hotel related okay and it's
almost
you know what I actually I wrote a Yelp
review recently for this hotel that I
love called Two Bunch Palms which is
this very cool special hotel in Palm
Desert which is a next to Palm Springs
and it has hot springs and it's like so
special and all of these people were
complaining because
all these rich people started going and
they're like oh
and it's like not that kind of place and
I was like lowering the reviews and I
had been going there for so many years
that I felt like I should step up I
should say like if you're expecting the
Four Season service like pool pool bar
it's not this kind of place so she left
a good Yelp review I left a good Yelp
review but I do remember staying at a
hotel that I was like appalled by in New
York that had like crusty carpet and I
because sometimes I do want to leave the
reviews so that people know because I
look at reviews sometimes and I'll stay
at places you know and so if someone
were to tell me that would have been
nice but it's so weird because everyone
has such a different you know reality of
or they have such different backgrounds
like what someone thinks is nice so why
are you listening to random people sure
true very true classy answer I know and
also do you see in her defense she's
smart she led with the one that she did
well yeah and then proceeded to talk
about how she dumped on a [ __ ] on a
business I respect that what's the
luggage situation
excuse me never tuck a bag even if I'm
going to Europe
um I'm I'm about to embark on a tour
right now
um and from New York so I'm in New York
and now tomorrow I go to Boston Philly
DC and I'm actually going to I've
collected a few things and so I asked
the hotel if they can ship all the stuff
I don't want whoa and they said sure no
problem welcome back to my house ground
shipping because I don't need it that
ain't the Holiday Inn I can tell you
that no way Jose and they they were like
oh yeah we can do that we'll just put it
in our mail and we have boxes here and
so now I'm just a small black I don't
even know what the brand is it's nothing
like fancy but it's like a roller sure
and I just wanna I just want to be able
to travel lightly that's my whole thing
is traveling lightly what what would it
take you for you to check a bag not like
I I'm going somewhere for a month okay
wow that would that would make me like
okay I have to like bring my big
suitcase
very classy answer yeah you fly first
class I assume no no no not always if
it's if it's like
a modest some more yeah I may
um but I don't think I'm flying first
class on any of my tour wow what's the
plastic you're using you have an AMEX
card I do it makes business
I think so it's silver the business it's
Platinum yeah I got them oh it's called
Platinum
the cameras
they'll rob you some people have their
agents out there some people have a gold
one yeah Platinum Silver's better oh it
is okay yeah
Capital One card no Discover card no
Diners Club come on what's the credit
score good credit score yeah but it took
me a long time yeah yeah well we had a
tear up through it yeah you'll get there
it didn't take that long it's kind of
funny like all of a sudden you're like
oh wait I can pay off this and when you
have an extra even if it's like hey I
have an extra 400 bucks I can start you
know yeah yeah uh if you make a purchase
with your card at uh at a store will you
get cash back if there's an option sure
you will good to have cash you don't
have any you got Franks on you right now
but I've run around with Deutsche marks
I always want to have you should always
have cash right yeah I mean you'll get
cash back from the cashier oh my my dad
used to have like a lot of cash in a
rubber band with a hundred on top and
all the ones so to my dad yeah are you
Italian no just a dirt bag I always keep
the heavy bike coming outside oh yeah
but my dad did have a money clip I gotta
say he didn't I think sometimes it was a
rubber band but usually it was like
because his money clip was you know
broken or something what kind of laundry
detergent do you use uh whatever has the
least scent I hate when garbage bags
have scent
is the trashiest thing it gets on your
fingers and stuff lilac smells like
vomit yeah that's horrible I don't want
anything to have a scent nothing like
scent free scent free what kind of
deodorant do you use uh I don't need
deodorant you don't use deodorant no
no sure I don't
I just never I'm part like
we're part native American and I heard
that Native Americans okay
that's why I don't know body wash or so
or bar
oh I'll switch it up whatever's like
comes to me whatever is like what is
that you're not using Dove or Irish
Spring or anything like that right
Dove isn't bad okay but no I I I would
probably yeah a body wash
but that's yeah essentially the shower
loofah do you use perfume at all no no
perfume not really okay I'm a little
sensitive towards it okay in the last
365 days have you said the phrase that's
how they get you no
you have any fireworks at the house no
take your shoes off at the house
I do most of the time but I encourage my
guests to not or to like that's the
classiest response if I go over your
house you make me take your shoes off
I'm never coming back no no no I would
never do that to somebody I always say
oh don't worry about it and if they want
to I say of course but sure okay okay
and then you know guys have like socks
in their holes in their socks yeah do
you currently own any celebrity cookware
um Wolfgang Puck this no no no how do
you feel about the rotisserie chicken
from like a grocery store yeah they're
good okay I mean I would buy it for my
daughter okay but I would prefer to
roast a chicken and
um of course we roast that's the only
thing I know how to cook or that's
something my friend taught me how to do
when I was that's a pretty classy dish
it's so easy you don't have to do
anything a couple of vegetables but the
vegetables you put your olive oil salt
pepper Rosemary put the lemon and garlic
inside the thing the next day you make
you make a chicken salad yes mayonnaise
Dijon it's all you really need cut it up
then the next day put that carcass in
and make a soup
that's kind of the self-sustaining
economy that's the weekend Shabbat goal
that's all right do you have any uh
fresh herbs at the house
I mean do you have like mint planted or
basil planted or anything like that no
that's a goal okay but you'll bring
you'll use fresh yeah yeah if I'm making
a chicken I'll make sure to buy it okay
and you know in La I kind of have don't
have a lot of things growing because
then it attracts animals sure and so
smart have you ever ordered anything off
QVC anything wrong oh give me a break
no no really I wasn't sure QVC I don't
know has anyone in your family ever had
any K jewelry no every kiss begins with
chaos yeah what are you talking about I
just picked up some items from Kate
Jones
some items
just the boxes
you have baking soda in your
refrigerator
three boxes yeah I mean we're I think
we're good here this is I I mean what
are we doing we're making ourselves look
like [ __ ] wait a minute I thought
she was gonna hit me that I asked her
about QVC ever been on a cruise no
have you ever eaten a hard-boiled egg in
public
because I try to give my daughter
protein so I'll put like um hard-boiled
egg I'll buy them from the store and
then slice it up and take out the egg
yolk she doesn't like that that's okay
she's a baby yeah that's true yeah
that's all right
um hard-boiled egg in public you take
your shoes off on the plane
sometimes yeah
you got me you ever brush your teeth in
the shower brush my teeth in the shower
for sure you do you pee in the shower
yes yes there we go we got her that's
not enough we got her she's got [ __ ]
French money on her what are we talking
about this is crazy this is I mean she
probably has gold bars in her bag what
the [ __ ] are we doing yeah Kruger in on
it all right this studio is worth more
money because she's in it the property
value's going out too I'm probably
getting a business loan
you know Natasha why can't you say
something
do you ever eat fast food
in and out that's it that's that's the
class that's classy God damn it yeah
I've had a seven layer burrito before
from Taco Bell
as a goof y I lost a bet
once he had two today what are you
talking about and you probably ate it
with a forking knife mine was only six
layer too I couldn't afford the cheese
probably had your assistant cut it up
for you gangs brand new book The World
deserves my children Natasha legero what
happens I'm not garbage
craziest person I've ever met
this is nuts yeah forget about Charles
with those sausage fingers get the kid
on there will you
congratulations on the book this is all
about motherhood this is all about your
fertility all that kind of your whole
journey with this uh yeah so I had a kid
you know I froze my eggs when I was 38 I
had a kid at 43 and uh I really
encourage all the women out there to try
to figure out a way to freeze your eggs
before you're 38 because then you have
two extra decades to uh find the right
guy and also earn some money and have a
career and find yourself and also uh I'm
going on a tour
dates all over I'm going on a tour and
it starts when does this come out uh
Monday oh okay yeah you told me that
so wait that's Monday it's Monday the
21st Monday would be the 21st yeah so
tonight I will be in Philadelphia the
21st Billy go out and sit here come on
and then I'm going the next day the 22nd
to Nashville and then the next day the
23rd to Denver and then I will be in
Chicago on the 28th and then I'm
retiring so come out and see me gang we
know most of you know Natasha but if you
don't she's an absolute killer you have
to go and see her she's absolutely
amazing congratulations on the new book
thank you so much we can't thank you
enough for coming and sitting with us
Kippy what do you got for the folks out
there guys we're over the road we have
some tickets left for the second show in
Boston second show in Rhode Island but
they're going quick get them while
they're there come see us gang we love
you very much and we'll see you next
week peace